we've long speculated that they will
criminally charge Joe Biden he will get
indicted and he will get arrested maybe
on the documents maybe on the corruption
and then they'll say we're not biased
we're going after Trump and Joe Biden
clearing the way for someone like Newsom
38 has them at a
rating right now and a 4 out of 10
approval wow so it's like historically
bad it's like I think only only behind
Carter right I mean it's it's awful and
it's been awful all the time and he's
not doing anything to make it better I
mean right now he's on his tour about
broadband internet which is interesting
and great but you actually can't have
him talk at all because and I this feels
so disrespectful to say but he is ill he
is not okay he is not full of being
compelling even with uh uh which should
be a slam dunk this Broadband tour you
know he he can't win support because the
more he's in public the more people
become concerned I think that part of
the reason I think I don't think that
that's a compelling issue for the
American people